E equals ABC squared you mentioned how
amazing is that to you that energy and
mass are the same
and what does that have to do with
nuclear fusion
so it has to do with everything we do
it's the fact that energy and mass are
equivalent to each other they're just
the way we usually comment to it is that
they're Just Energy just in different
forms can you intuitively understand
that yes but it takes a long time I
um I haven't for all but usually often
I've I teach the um the introductory
class for incoming nuclear engineers and
and so we put this up as an equation and
we go through many iterations of using
this uh to how you derive it how you use
it and so forth and then you usually in
the final exam I would give I would
basically take all the equations that
I've used before and I flip it around I
basically instead of thinking about
energy is equal to mass is sort of mass
is equal to energy and I asked the
question in a different way and usually
what half the students don't get it it
takes a while is to get that intuition
yeah
um so so in the end it's interesting is
that this is is actually the source of
all free energy because that energy that
we're talking about is kinetic energy if
it can be transformed from Mass so it
turns out even even though we we used
equals MC square this is burning coal
and and burning gas are and burning wood
is actually still equals mc squared the
problem is that you would never know
this because the relative change in the
mass is incredibly small by the way
which comes back to Fusion which is that
E equals m c squared okay so what does
this mean it tells you that the the
amount of energy that is liberated in a
particular reaction when you change Mass
has to because c squared is that's the
speed of light squared it's a large
number it's a very large number and it's
totally constant everywhere in the
universe which is which is another weird
thing which is another weird thing and
in all rest frames and the actually the
relatively stuff gets more
difficult conceptually even until you
get through anyway so you go you go to
that and and it's and what that tells
you is that it's the relative it's the
relative change in the mass we'll tell
you about the relative amount of energy
that's liberated and this is what makes
fusion and you asked about Fusion as
well too this is what makes them
extraordinary it's because the relative
change in the mass is very large as
compared to what you get like in a
chemical reaction in fact it's about
it's about 10 million times larger
and that is at the heart of why you use
something like Fusion it's because that
is a fundamental of nature like you
can't beat that so of whatever you do if
you're thinking about and why do I care
about this well because Mass is like the
fuel right so this means Gathering the
resources that it takes to gather a fuel
to hold it together to deal with it the
environmental impact it would have and
fusion will always have 20 million times
the amount of energy release per
reaction that you could have those so
this is why you know we consider it the
ultimate like environmentally friendly
energy source is because of that so is
it is it correct to think of mass
broadly as a kind of storage of energy
yes